el jugador con más títulos de la
historia del fútbol en prisión
preventiva en España el futbolista
brasileño de 39 años Dani Alves está
acusado de haber violado a una joven de
23 años en los baños de una discoteca de
Barcelona la abogada y activista
feminista Nuria González analizó la
decisión judicial en France 24 atención
de Dani Alves viene dada por la
declaración de la víctima que es muy
clara que es totalmente coherente y
sobre todo por las pruebas eso la falta
de arraigo de Dani Alves en España y en
la capacidad económica de Dani Alves
para salir irse y desaparecer donde
quiera es lo que han lo que han hecho
que la fuerza dictada prisión preventiva
sin fianza no que es lo que quizá más ha
sorprendido a todo el mundo la policía
revisó las cámaras habló con testigos Y
tomó declaración a la víctima el mismo
día de los hechos esta mantuvo su
versión de forma persistente días
después delante de la jueza por su parte
el exjugador del Fútbol Club Barcelona
Dani cambió tres veces su declaración y
llegó a decir que fue la víctima quien
le asaltó sexualmente siempre se pone en
duda la versión de la víctima de hecho
es tristísima tenga más credibilidad en
este caso ella ha decidido renunciar a
su derecho a una indemnización para que
nadie vaya a decir que es que está en
esto por dinero es absolutamente
denigrante que una víctima tenga que
renunciar a sus derechos para ser para
tener más credibilidad entonces Dani
Alves cuando hace gala de esa soberbia
pues está un poco en lo cierto porque
claramente vemos que las versiones de
las mujeres siempre se ponen en duda
Daniel Alves estará en prisión
preventiva hasta que se celebre el
juicio la ley en España contempla apenas
de entre 4 a 12 años de cárcel para este
tipo de delitos Mientras tanto el equipo
del que Dani Alves formaba parte en el
momento de los hechos El Pumas mexicano
rescindió su contrato